hello everyone
um you may not know
enablement and machine learning
enablement so today I'm going to speak
about that and first I'd like to start
with a story
um early in the morning
Andrew wakes up and he's already ready
to go to the Sea
it climb on his small fishing boat
he breathes deeply and smells the small
tear departing from the our board and
added out to the open ocean is both
rocks gently
passionately is kind of the reason for
any sign of life until its catch is
Catch of fish a silverfish
and Andrew repeating this process time
and time again always catching some fish
the other fishermen in the area notice
Andrew's success
and one day they gather around Andrew's
boat eager to know his secrets
and without hesitation Andrew shared is
three secrets
first he explained that he spent hours
Studio studying the weather conditions
and sea patterns
by compiling data from previous shares
it determine determines the best places
to fish
secondly
it revealed that he meticulously
prepared his equipment
he ensures that every hook and line is
ready and in perfect working order
according to his strategy
and third
he shared that he never forgot the
importance of his family because the
happy life was the intimate goal in life
the other fishermen were Amazed by
Andrew dedication to detail
and they started to flow his advice
at first it was tough because they were
catching only infraction of what Andrew
was catching
but with time and practice they began to
see results
they were catching even more fish than
they ever ever caught before
and their family was appeared to
in this story there is several roles
can you give me the team
that is enabled
one end
no gas
the fisherman the fisherman was unable
to fish more
there is there any support team in this
story
the family yes thank you families
supporting the fisherman
and who's the enabler
okay
yes thank you thank you so
let me present myself and we'll explain
you the link with my role
so I'm Jan lebanier a new animal in the
zoo a machine learning enabler
I'm here because I like python I
discovered this 10 years ago and it
changed my career I was a mechanical
engineer and now I'm managing learning
enabler
and also I'm here because I like AI you
can automate tasks it's kind of a child
dream to learn and to build something
that can work for you
and also I like agile this uh
uh logo is as I would like agile because
we are living in a ever evolving world
and we need to have a certain way of
working to adapt to this ever avering
world
and I like uh I work for adivinta
and I will present you add event because
it's the a non-broned brand of many
brand that you may know
in fact adivinta is a leader in the
second end Marketplace
it holds Market pieces in several
countries in the world you may know in
Germany eBay
in France there is a big Marketplace
called Le bonquin and in Spain there is
a lot of marketplaces Milan milanunciano
coaches info jobs are the main ones and
in Italy there is subito and all these
marketplaces belongs and run to and work
together inside ADI winter
we are thousands of employees inside the
product and technology department and
there are also a global product and
technology and Central teams that are
leveraging infrastructure and so on for
every marketplaces
no I will introduce a bit more the topic
of this talk
when you come across an organization
larger organ or small organization you
can find different kind of teams and
with data scientists we you can have
like future teams with a small number of
data scientists that are building uh
customer facing features you can also
find large
team with more data scientists that are
building
models or predictions for other teams
and this in fact was modeled by Matthew
skeleton and Manuel pies in their book
team topologies and in this book you can
find four teams it's a it's a model so
you can find it or not in your in your
company but first first kind is the
stream align team it's around 80 to 90
percent of sugar of many organizations
and it's what we call the future teams
um second kind that I want to speak
about is the complicated subsystem team
engineer ID
based on specific knowledge so you need
to rely on Expert or specific knowledge
like data science and so on
uh the third team that we can find is
the platform team so this platform team
will build the infrastructure and the
services that will be used by the other
teams and the first team is the enabling
team and this team help the other teams
to acquire new capabilities
and I'm working in the team of enablers
we are working into different kinds of
capabilities there is security messaging
and also machine learning and I'm here
today to talk about my machine learning
enabler role
so what's a machine learning enabler you
may wonder what's the difference with a
machine learning engineer
why a new name for something that looks
the same
in fact the focus of the machine
learning enabler
is more large than the machine learning
engineer
you will work on the infrastructure also
on the tools and also on the team and
the work on the team level is about
skills of the team about knowledge of
the team and so on
and you may Wonder okay why would I need
it maybe the manager can do it or not
and we'll see why
so why any machine learning linear
enabler so according to Gartner in 2022
the big companies I.T leaders they
struggle to integrate AI within
applications and they're wasting a lot
of time and money into AI projects that
are never put into production and I've
seen that in some companies and and even
if there is this product in production
they're struggling to retain value
so let's see why it's difficult
in fact creating a model is not
difficult but putting the model in
production and inferior doing inference
in real time for a large volume is
something different you need to have
quality and so on and it's based on a
deep stack it involves infrastructure
narcissist resting system and a lot of
knowledge into data science to perform
all the tasks inside this this deep
stack
in fact when you start in data sense you
always kind of always start with
notebooks notebooks are great for
exploration for analysis and so on but
when you want to go to production
notebooks not really a good idea you can
do you can try but it may be difficult
um so this kind of starts with the
problem and we can see that if you
follow the notebook approach you will
start to work sequentially because you
we will want to explore your data then
build the best model and when you are
ready with your best model then you
start to put it into production and as I
said we are in an available in world so
this implies some complication and then
comes the bottleneck is here or to come
from a model to to be producing real
value for the customer
so what are the consequences of this
bottleneck in fact in terms of business
it's really a big issue because you can
find an opportunity to have a business
Advantage but if it if it takes you
months to deliver the model into
production and to predict the values
then you may lose or not gain your
competitive advantage
and second in terms of Team coordination
if you have a team that is producing
models and then it takes months and then
the team that receive the models they
look at the result and it's not it's not
okay with them they want to change
something
if it takes you months again to create a
new model version and then to release it
then
everyone is losing time here
so we are adding to the second part of
this talk is how to improve this
situation
so
for about a year ago was contacted so I
changed a bit in my talk here because of
these Keynotes this morning so I thought
about this do thing so a year ago I was
contacted on LinkedIn someone contacted
me and well yeah we have a role of
machine learning and developer want to
join in the interview process and so on
and was like what this machine learning
enabler
and in fact it took me about eight to
nine months to understand really what it
was so this is why I'm presenting you in
this today
and when you start as a machine learning
enabler you will see in a company many
models that are really already built and
ready to be in production sometimes
already in Productions and
[Music]
Your Role here as a machine learning
enabler is to streamline all this
process of making a machine learning
model from just a machine learning
mining oh sorry just a machine learning
model to a production an actual
something in in production and what is
required for that is first artwork
because you need to uh
interact with a lot of people
infrastructure data science team
machine learning engineer and so on and
also the infrastructure so you will need
to combine basically what it takes to to
create mlops but also I would say people
skill you need to go to each place and
find the right people talk with them
convince them that what you want to do
is best for them and to help them to
grow and this is something that I
discovered later on when I was already
working
and in the end you see some real
benefits about bringing people together
and to producing something
and I'll show you how we do it at a
diving down so here is the bay the
Baseline I would say the stock starting
point it's ground level of my envelopes
it's the a picture that I took from the
ml Ops page from Google and in fact you
can see in this in this diagram all the
basic steps that we do to build the
model so we we extract some data analyze
it do some data preparation we train the
model then we evaluate the model and so
on we store the model into a model
registry and we use the model into the
model registry to to create an
application that will serve the model
and this ground level as you can see is
based on all the money all the
experimentation is manual that you often
do it on on notebooks and you iterate on
it and so on
and now we'll see what can be the the
Target that we want to achieve
so this is level two I skip one level
because there is not much difference
into one and two
and the main differences are that their
experimentation phase is already inside
an orchestrating system so you don't
work anymore on notebooks you're already
using a pipeline into your developmental
environment
the second part is that you're using CI
to build and test your packages
you're not using the notebooks to store
your code you store your code inside
real python file and inside the GitHub
git Repository
and you use the CI to to make it
released to to pass some tests to Big
release and then there is a c is a
common continuous deployment pipeline to
deploy the orchestraction pipeline that
you you developed inside another
environment and sometimes there is
several environment at this stage there
is pre-production and production
and you will you will see there is all
the same steps but it's inside the
pipeline
and in the end it's the pre-production
or production environment that we create
the model and put it into the model
registry
after that we we see another pipeline
which is also a continuous deployment
pipeline for serving the models into an
application and then when you have an
application running
you will need to follow the performance
of the model because uh you were you you
wanted to behave well for the users have
a low latency and not use too much
cost into infrastructure and so on
so let's see what we can do to make it
happen
we choose to create our own
infrastructure it's a fleet of
kubernetes clusters and each team can
have a collection of humanities cluster
it comes in three flavor for development
pre-production and production and the
teams can use the service all they want
it's it's
um it's a space for the data scientists
to experiment into the development
environment and then to move forward to
pre-production and production gradually
keeping the same code from the
experiment until the production
and one year ago we looked at that even
tougher machine learning initiative and
we asked the teams how much time they
detects for you to serve a model into
production so put prediction and do
inference into production
from the time that you you have the the
data available and the average answer
was around 50 days and in some teams it
can go up to 80 days so it's about a
quarter
and
we we built some tools and on in support
of this of this platform to enhance the
situation
so we are using golden pass it's a
concept that we are use using from
Spotify
and the golden pass consists of uh
guidelines and best practices that you
can you can use to deploy a machine
learning model
and there is some templates for your
project to uh to be kicked off and also
some libraries that will help to
abstract the complexity of building
Docker images putting the artifact into
artifactories and pushing everything out
there
and we spawned inside the machine
learning acceleration program we spawn
the team of machine learning enables so
I'm just one piece of a victim of
machine learning enablers that are
working on each market faces as you can
see
and how do we work we we work with the
managers we we go with a team and we
speak about agility we speak about the
composition of the team we speak about
the the skills of the team or can we
upskill the team on certain areas
and we provide to the team the best
practices in ml Ops how to use the the
platform we provide workshops for
onboarding the platform
and in the end for the first iterations
we provide support for the for the team
when they want to use the platform
and
when we approach the team we have a
machine learning Matrix machine learning
maturity Matrix
that we use to assess the level of
support that we will need to provide to
a team so it's kind of a questionnaire
that you will answer and say okay I'm
I'm good with operational content
continuous deployment and so on or not
and then we we can assess Where You Are
and today by implementing all these all
these setup we are releasing the time to
deploy a machine learning model down to
30 days and our objective is to go to
one Sprint so two weeks
here's some are we going going to give
you some practical advice that you can
get by with you
so the first one is to set clear
relationships between your data
environment and your orchestration
environments so in the vertical box you
can see the Unicron clusters and in
other horizontal there is the data
sources with the feature store and the
cluster the eks cluster that can deploy
the application in production or QA
environment and you can as you can see
there there is uh the development
cluster can only read and write on QA
and the production cluster can only read
and write on production and in the
middle it's the kind of transition step
you can read and write on QA but only
read on production and so be careful
also because you agree on production you
can have some impact on the production
database databases but if you do it
correctly then you're good with some
kind of setup like this because you can
move the the code the pipeline codes to
more data and more real implementation
um on the on the tool level we can also
look at inside the orchestraunching
pipeline what can we do to make it
better so here you can see on the left
there is the data source in the middle
the second box it's the Unicron cluster
then we have ml float store the model
and then the deployment application
and in fact we can create to help the
team we can create component inside Q
Pro or the across creating pipeline that
you you want to use we can create
components that will help accessing the
data for everyone to assess the model
performance to do model registration
inside
um ml flow or whatever other model
registry that you want to use and the ID
is in order to help the team create more
abstractions create a purse that will
abstract the complexity and then it will
be easier to to be used
so since we are working with teams we
need to use a change model it's the
people part that we'll talk now
so what I are using is the ad car model
it's the prescriptive model I've not
invented it it's already done by many
people mostly coach in agile
and a stands for awareness it's the
awareness that there is something to
change to become better to have more
efficiency and so on D is the desire and
you can spark the desire as a change
operator but it's mainly in the team's
end if a team doesn't want to to change
it doesn't have the desire it doesn't
have the energy to go forward so we want
to to have a good desire to move forward
okay stands for knowledge because there
is some change we need to bring some
knowledge so that's why the enablers
they bring workshops to help the team to
grow and to learn new things
the second A is for Ability at some
point you will be able to acquire new
skills and that's what you're getting
with you whatever you go next
and R stands for reinforcement because
you want to emphasize the benefits of
the change when the first results come
then you unphasis this good positive
result and keeping the desire and the
energy of the of the team
and there is awareness we can use a tool
that is called value stream mapping
and this tool will help you yeah
understand how you create value in a
team
so this is a kind of picture that will
be describing it you you need a timeline
and you will draw on this time where the
team is actively working and what it is
doing and where the team is depending on
other parts
and you will so learn the dependencies
of the team to the to the other part of
the organization or an external services
or something like that
and it will help you to spark the
discussion of how we can improve the
machine learning workflow or we can
improve to go into production faster and
so on
and changing steam it takes a long time
so start this kind of discussion early
and be patient
to summarize this talk there is three
key points machine learning enabler
averse in fact changing the organization
both us at Team level and infrastructure
and tools you will need to bring
everyone together
and building an infrastructure is a key
to go from notebooks to Something in
real production you can build it for you
or you can use manage services existing
on cloud platforms
and you will need to build helpers
depending on the team maturity
don't wait for an enabler to start the
change you may not have an enabler in
your team but use these tips and think
about what you can do to improve your
machine learning workflow
and just to close the story just to
close the talk
um I want to come back to the story of
the beginning there is a fourth secret
from Andrew
in fact either ways that he always stay
open mind to new ideas and techniques
and with time the other fishermen
started to also follow this as Dice and
they became good friend and they started
to share a lot of knowledge with each
other and with other fishermen and
everyone was happy
thank you everyone for this talk
great
thank you so much yeah that was a very
fascinating talk welcome to the we
welcome this new animal in the zoo okay
we have a couple of questions on slido
and I think this first question goes
really well with the last thing that you
said is the ml enabler needed in small
companies with good communication
between teams what percentage of time
well okay and the next part of that
question is what percentage of time do
you spend coding okay the first first
part
um you don't need to have a specific
role as any ml enabler to be an enabler
you can be a machine learning an
engineer and do some enabling and speak
if you are in a small company you're in
close relation with the rulings
organization so it's more easier to to
be in contact with everyone so you don't
need to be their role and the second
part is what a percentage of timeline
Spain coding so it's difficult to assess
but I'm alternating sometimes I'm coding
um or the week and sometimes I'm
supporting so it's not recording by
myself but bare coding and sometimes I'm
doing meetings like everyone but I would
say like around 50 percent
cool it's a good rate I think
okay next question are Dev pre and Pro
pre and pro cluster is technically
identical or could there be version
mismatches
um we can we can have variations we use
github's methodology to to deploy them
so we have a git repository with three
branches one for Dev one from prey one
for pro and you can do variations inside
these branches because these branches
with will be the declarative way to
create the Clusters
okay
how can I transition from data science
to ml apps
I mean how easy or difficult it is I
don't know if you can answer this
question but you can try yes uh it's
it's complex
um
from my experience
um okay I can tell you what I do what I
did I was data scientist then I found a
job in data engineering and then I was
more like a ml engineer
so it's kind of learning the cloud
um you need test and so all the software
engineering bring the engineering inside
the data scientist
what were the most useful best practices
that the data scientists learned
um
you can ask they're here there's my
colleagues here
um I don't know I would say
leaving the notebooks for orchestructing
pipeline would be the most effective
okay
why do you train your models twice in
cicd Pre and pride
um
because because
it happens that sometimes when you
using reusing some models then you
override the wrong model and you want to
see that in pre-production and not in
production
okay
will the data scientist work on dev
preprod and prod or only on prod
environment
yeah me neither
uh okay I don't understand the question
I'm sorry whoever wrote this please
rephrase okay I'm just gonna move on to
the next one how does your role overlap
with solution architecture and what are
the differences
um I don't know much about solution
Architects
um
but I would say that my role is more in
discussion with this kind of profile and
I don't decide by myself anything in
fact I'm depending on everyone and the
Good Will of everyone
is there any ml enabler certificate
already
oh I don't think so yeah if you were to
certify um if you would certify I will
use a facilitator
in management 3.0 certification
it's kind of thing that about New
Management way into the IGI world right
what is the maximum size a data
scientist a data science team should
have before splitting up
good question depends on how much time
you want to spend on the
yeah um I don't know
uh I guess last question uh can you
explain the path of a project from Dev
over pre to prod
project would be like um
the idea is in two weeks create a
baseline project model into the
development orchestraction pipeline so
that's at the end with your Baseline
product
model you are able to push the pipeline
up to production and then after iterate
on it
with the coming spring
okay
thank you so much Jan and thank you
everybody for your participation
yay